what's up everybody were pond finiti and
welcome to another episode of challenge
from Trinity this is the series where
you challenge us with your craziest
ideas related to table tennis we'll go
through all your comments in the comment
section and choose the best and most
creative ideas and use them in our next
video so make sure to leave your comment
in the comment section below and we'll
give you a shout out in the next video
so Jake Reynolds wants us to play table
tennis over the curtains if you mean
these curtains that's gonna be difficult
but let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Caleb Clarkson asks if we can split the
table tennis ball by heating it at a
sharp upright tonight thanks for the
idea Caleb we'll give it a try
[Music]
next that Alex organized games wants to
play a one-minute rally of only using
under the leg shots or behind the back
shots I'll go behind the back you go
between the legs
sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay the next suggestion is from garland
Blow and he wants us to rip a piece of
paper with a pink book well it didn't
quite rip but we made a hole
[Music]
[Applause]
they're now script
[Music]
thanks for your really good ideas we had
a great time filming today's session
make sure to subscribe to the channel by
clicking here and don't forget to leave
your ideas in the comment section below
until next time